hello thank you for having me
here uh so I'll be talking about the T
of squares problem and could you speak
louder
please turn the mic
up be light at the top of
bottom better no okay so sums of squares
problem and families of antic committing
m
uh uh the sums of squares problem is one
of my favorite problems about pols I
don't know how to solve it so uh
basically this talk is more about
advertising the problem than my own work
about it uh the problem is very nice so
uh it's the following so the sum of sums
of squares
problem uh you have the following
polinomial X1 2 + X2 2
x y1 2 + Y 2
2 y s and you want to write it as a sum
of squares F1 s
F2 plus
FK FS are some uh real
pols and you want to know how many such
squares you
need uh to be more exact see I want to
know uh
given an N what is the
smallest smallest
K such that there exist
real
pols F1 through
FK so that uh the following identity
holds
I will denote s of
n the smallest T
K it's a very simple
question you can uh see quite easily
that the trivial bounce on S of n
is somewhere between n² and n the upper
on is easy because if you just open the
brackets then you will just uh write
this thing as
simply sum of all x i y j squared so you
need n well actually it should be
probably n Square over two or n choose
two something like that um o n s or n
squ yeah sorry n Square the
there uh yes to see the lower bound uh
it's an exercise that you can
complete uh actually the upper bound can
be a little bit improved and you can
actually get uh o of n² over log
n uh and we will see where the lock
comes from a little bit later but this
is essentially the best upper bound this
is the best upper bound that we know on
this question it also shows that the
trivial uh uh upper bound is not uh what
you will be
getting the I assume this is clear nice
ask a really nice question if if I
replace all the X squs with x's and all
the Y squ with y's I have a really easy
problem there so like what what's going
on uh you will replace uh just take the
product of two linear forms then that's
easy
to uh you want to over complex numbers
maybe I'm asking a different question
okay if you ask this question over
complex numbers then any polinomial over
complex numbers can be written as a sum
of two squares so over algebraically
closed field this is format the product
of two uh no any polinomial anything can
be written like you can write okay you
can write f as something like f + 1 s -
F -1 2 over 4 and you take the square
roots uh so over complex numbers this
question if you want to make this
question meaningful you and actually
like the formulation over complex
numbers better that you would add the
extra conditions that the real
polinomial would be complex polinomial
but you would require them to be
homogeneous of degree 2 and bilinear in
the variables X and Y so I actually
would prefer to State over complex
numbers in this way using the condition
of bilinearity on the fs uh but I didn't
want to get into it so I chose the real
numbers instead thank you
for of course if you figure out the
trivial upper bound which is like 2 N I
will be very happy to know that because
my guess would be that this is actually
the correct answer uh for this
function uh I I should also say that I
don't really care about the exact value
of n i I just want to know whether it
looks more like n or it looks more like
n squ uh so is it more like linear
function or more like a quadratic
function and that's the main question
the reason why I was interested in this
was that long time ago with
victorson
off we show that if you can prove that
SN
is of this
form so if you show that it is super
linear for
some Sal bigger than zero then you get a
circuit lower
bounds so lower bounds in some model
that I will not describe but that was
the original motivation so originally I
wanted uh to know whether
the uh you can get linear number of
squares or whether you need Super linear
so this was the original application uh
in the meantime I completely forgot
about it and I think this is interesting
and it's in itself yes does the field
matter I mean uh that's a good question
I think it shouldn't uh so as long as
the field is of characteristics
different than two if the field
characteristics two then the problem
really trivializes but uh uh I think the
problem makes sense for every field uh
as long as you again insist that those
FS are
billionaire and I don't see why the
field should me but I cannot prove that
it's field independent so uh I would
guess that over any field this is the
correct answer so for rational versus
real for uh yeah yeah I think it should
be the same the same well I think it is
the same but I don't know how to prove
that
uh yes well it could happen that
like you could use some irrational
numbers here I know why it should should
help or not could could you say just a
word about what kind of circuit lower
bounds for what uh so there is a it's
arithmetic circuits so circuits which
compute polinomial but it's actually
arithmetic circuits which use
noncommutative Gates so you assume that
multiplication is
non-commutative uh you can think about
uh it that you are Computing over a
matrix algebra or something like that so
it's a very simple model but we still
don't know low bands for for this uh
type of circuits and solving this
question should uh would prove a low
band uh I don't remember now where I
said it but this is not in order to make
this work you actually need to work over
algebraically closed field uh that is
not in this formulation so this is sort
of little bit of a
cheap but uh the reason why uh the this
question was interesting to people much
earlier uh which you may be familiar
with for people are interested in
specific values of the function in
specific identities of this
form and uh so I'll just give you few
values of this function S1 for powers of
two so here you get just the identity X1
y1 2 is X1 y1
SP now if you look at this case the case
of two there is a nice formula which
says uh the only reason why remember it
is that it is very simple interpretation
so if you think about the complex number
X1 plus
ix2 has another complex number which is
y1 Y
2 then then this
thing is the norm of the complex number
x² y^ 2 now this is the real part of the
product and this is the imaginary part
of the product so so this expresses the
identity that uh the norm of complex
numbers is
multiplicate uh there is a similar
identity which I will not write
down uh for four
squares uh which expresses the same fact
for uh quat
Neons and uh the identity was discovered
before quaternion and it was due to
Oiler I
think and there is a similar identity
for S of = 8 which expresses the same
fact
for now if you look at this sequence
people probably thought for a while that
uh this will go forever and you will
have S of 16 is equal to
16 uh but hit proved in late 18 19th
century so the equal is a less than or
equal right no it's exactly equal we you
know SN is always at least n and so the
trivial part of course is less of but
it's
equality uh so whoit proved and if I
have the time I'll will sketch this
theorem in a
moment that
uh those are actually the only cases
where the equality holds otherwise you
must have strict inequality and he
proved that s of n is equal to n if and
only if n is either 1 2 4 8 so in all
the other cases n must be strictly s of
n must be strictly bigger than
n so the natural guess for the
continuation of the pattern would be
some like Clifford OBS EXC the natural
guess for the continuation of the
pattern would be something like Clifford
algebras oh yes that's the this is very
related to there's also there's a
sequence of of algebras of order 2 to
the N which are weaker and weaker
conditions
discover you and that's that's all but
they're not normed in the sense that's
probably yeah CLI algebraist you still
have the kind of structure you want
here yeah but yeah the natural way how
to continue the sequence is through
Clifford algebras uh but then you it no
longer gives sums of spares formulas
because you don't have the norm uh
notion
um so this is the problem this is
probably the nicest thing you can say
about the problem there are a lot of
other nice things which I will not go
into uh now how does it relate to
families of anticommuting matrices so uh
it relates because uh I had a very
beautiful approach how to solve this
problem and uh it turned out I actually
can't so the only thing that came out of
it is the following conjecture which I
will state I will give you a few things
that I uh know about it which which
would somehow resolve this problem so
the conjecture is the
following so let's have matrices E1
through
e which now will be complex n byn
matrices uh which are antic
commutative
uh by this I mean simply that EI * EJ is
equal to minus EJ
EI uh
whenever I is not equal to J I apologize
I write subscripts with capitals it's
not an ideal just a natural number okay
so uh if you take any uh The Matrix is
anticommute uh any two matrices
anticommute uh then the following
holds if you take the Matrix this is you
square
them then you get at
most o n
n so the statement is trying to tell you
that if you it's not easy to construct
anti-com matrices antic commutative is
is quite a strong
condition some of the ranks ranks some
of the ranks this is the rank
so uh it's not easy to construct
anticommuting matrices this is trying to
tell you that if you uh have a set of
anticommuting matrices then the ranks of
the matrices of the family cannot be too
large the square on the inside or the
outside it's on the
inside uh that's quite important I will
mention it well I can as well mention it
right now so one way how to bound this
of course would be to bound just is the
sum of the ranks instead of the ranks
squared but uh one thing about this is
that the sum of the ranks as you see uh
doesn't depend on K at all it should
depend only on the dimension of the
space that the Matrix is living if you
were trying to uh consider the sum of
the ranks uh it will no longer be the
case because if you look
at the simp way how to construct
anticommuting matrices it's think about
2x two matrices which look like this
if you take any two matrices of this
kind you get a
zero uh but over complex numbers you
have infinitely many such matrices so uh
if you were counting the sum of the
ranks you would be getting a number
which is as large as you wish or can be
infinite if you allow the family to be
infinite so that's one reason why I uh
why you are counting the the rank
squared that's the rank of the Matrix
squared or the rank squared rank of the
Matrix
Square
uh so is eight minutes 8 minutes
great so that's why the square is inside
not on the outside if the rank was on
the outside uh the uh the upper bound
could be any number you want uh which
could be arbitr
large uh the reason why this is uh
this conjecture is designed so that uh
it implies
that uh that SN is
actually so it implies that this bound
is
tight uh that's one reason why I believe
it because it seems uh uh uh it's would
imply what I want but I I spend a lot of
time trying to find a counter example
but I couldn't find it
either another reason why this is
U
uh why one would think that the log why
the formula looks like n log n here and
n² over log n here is a simple fact
which
uh is actually a fact which is used in
the proof of the horites
theorem which is that if you have uh E1
through e k which are anti-c
commutative and full
rank uh then K is at most 2 log
n
in other words one way how to uh if you
wanted to obtain your family of anti
commuted anticommuting matrices by
having the rank of each Matrix to be as
large as possible namely to have full
rank uh then the number of such matrices
will be at most uh roughly Logan and in
this case actually this bound is
achieved so what you are trying to say
here is that the best thing you can
do in order to construct a family of
anticommuting matrixes is indeed to take
matrices of really high
rank and uh somehow everything else you
can do is uh will be just worse or at
least it will not be
better I will state okay I thought I'll
have time to sketch you proof of this
thing because it's a really nice
theorem uh which I will not have time to
do but
U which involves proving this statement
which is
uh Elementary and nice but instead I
will State uh two things that one can
prove about this one thing is that this
quantity is actually bounded by some
function of n so at least it's not an
infinite thing uh more exactly uh you
can prove Pro that if E1 through EK are
anti-commuting
and for all I EI s is not equal to
zero which you can always assume because
otherwise you just throw the Matrix
away uh this implies that K is at most 2
a so if you have the condition that you
have an anti-commuting family of
matrices each of them Squares to
something which is non zero unlike in
this case because all of those matrices
squared to
zero then the number of such matrices
must be finite and in par it's bounded
by 2 N which also implies that the sum
of the
rank squared is at most
uh roughly n squ okay so instead of
getting n log n you can get at least n^
s and another thing uh one can prove is
that
uh again if you have a family of
anticommuting matrices then the
following holds there exists an R which
is always smaller than n such that
instead of summing the squares the ranks
of the squares of the
matrices you sum the ranks of EI to R
and this is indeed bounded
by uh so uh obviously as if you are
increasing powers of the matrices the
rank will be going down or at least it's
not going to go up so the higher and
higher powers of E you take and uh you
are counting the ranks the rank will go
down what is this telling you that it's
enough to take uh the power to be let's
say n
and uh the conjuncture will be true if
you replace this two by say
n one cor corollary of this is obviously
that if you take diagonalizable matrices
diagonalizable matrices have the
property that EI squ is the rank of EI
squ is still
EI uh so this implies that if uh E1
through
EK uh are Diagon
diagonalizable by which I mean each of
them is diagonalizable separately not
that they would be diagonalizable
together then actually the
rank
EI is at
most
and here we don't need a
square well so this is pretty much that
I know about it the punchline of this is
that uh the hard case if you look at
this
thing is actually the case when uh each
Matrix EI is nil potent that's the most
problematic case because if it's nil
potent then you raise it to a power of n
and it just vanishes so this theorem
tells you absolutely nothing uh also of
course nilp matrices are not
diagonalizable so uh here you also get
nothing so really the uh the bottleneck
of this whole uh thing is
to uh make it work for
uh nail poent
matrices and uh or if you have some
other idea how to deal with this
question I'll be happy if you solve it
in some other way and if you have uh
even a counter example this conjecture
it would also make me very happy thank
you yes so have you tried topological
methods for this
conjecture yes uh well I mean it looks
like you know the old one is Vector
fields on sphere this could be something
like vector bundle on sphere yes that's
uh well I
uh I did try and this
guy Mr Amud he did try uh also and then
we sort of came to the conclusion that
uh in those topological methods you work
hard and hard and then you get here a
factor of
two yeah but I I just went for this
specific conjecture uh for the specific
no because I thought uh well those are
just matrices but the the theorem you
are referring to is that uh
somehow this
statement really uses the fact that uh
uh you have full rank matri no that
that's why I said Vector bundle and not
Vector field because this the vector
bundle will give you extra
flexibility no I didn't uh I didn't uh
if you have like an idea how to do it I
would be very happy well we could talk
but I don't know if it's worth
anything other questions or
comments experiments with some of
Square's
optimization uh you mean a
computer
uh well we were trying to force some
grad students to implement it and nobody
was uh willing to do it and I don't know
how to program if you are offering uh
that you will do it l
be you solve my
problem no like the problem is okay yes
no I think it's I think it's such a
Charming test case to to try to find a
low rank point on this spectr spect yeah
but we thought okay seriously we we
thought about it and now uh like the
values of these functions are pretty
known accur exactly up to like 10 for
six 16 it's roughly uh it's uh known
that the number is somewhere between 32
and something else but uh I think even
for 16 it's impossible to State this in
a feasible way that you could actually
get something so uh I don't think we
have computational power to handle even
the case of
16 what that say nals 6 what's the set
of all representations oh there's a semi
albra except all representations of this
kind 4 six I think like up to 10 the
answer is completely known and like
there are I'm not very good with
references but there is a lot of
literature about this and a lot of
literature actually focused or most of
literature focused on Computing the
exact values of this fun I don't mean
the value I mean the set of all
representations uh I would guess it also
has been done but uh the I I just don't
know how it would generalize for for
General
n can we assume in the original
formulation of the problem that PO are
without that's that's a very good point
so without
loss which of course was the case here
and it's the case in in
general so with your conure is there an
elementary sort of large block Matrix
whose rank is O of n log n if they ENT
is there
some uh could you repeat that so I'm
wondering if you have a large blocked
Matrix whose blocks are either zero or
e13 k whose rank is this number that
you're looking for uh yeah well that's
actually uh yes I mean if if I have a
block Matrix with the squares on the
diagonal then fine but then I'm asking
maybe it comes from a different
construction so this is actually one
other way how to phrase the sum of
squares problem which so if you take
those matrices you write them like
this so then on the diagonals you have
those EI squares and if you look at this
block and the complementary block on the
other side they are the opposite of each
other um that's one observation if you
want to solve the sum of squares problem
you can phrase it completely differently
in a which looks somewhat like the
picture over there so think about the
following Matrix which is divided into
blocks and the Matrix will have size n^2
by n² and you will have n block box each
of sides n by
n now the condition is that on the
diagonal you will have the identity
Matrix that is n by and identity
Matrix and if you look at this block and
the complementary block so the E here
you must have minus V so that's the
constraint on The Matrix and what you
want to do you want to minimize the rank
of such a matrix so the trivial way how
to uh if you just write the over
diagonal blocks to be zeros then the
rank will be n squ the question is can
you fill in those matrices which satisfy
the antisymmetric condition in such a
way that the rank will drop to let's say
n of course you can't make it smaller
than n because there are those
identities sitting here but the question
is like where does the rank of this
Matrix sit so uh that may be like a
nicer way how to formulate this problem
except I don't know how to attack this
uh version at all but maybe a computer
could have
this yes
so thank
you